الخارجيه الامريكيه لا تستبعد تورط
اوكرانيا بتفجيرات ستريم وتصف التقارير
التي تتحدث عن تورط واشنطن بالسخيفه
[تصفيق]
لليوم الثاني على التوالي اشتباكات عنيفه
في جورجيا بين الشرطه والمحتاجين على
قانون جدلي حول الاعلام
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
وصفت الخارجيه الامريكيه وعلى لسان
المتحدث باسمها التقارير التي تتحدث عن
تورط واشنطن
لا ترفض اي روايه تشير الى العثور على
متورطين بهذا الحادث وعن تورط اوكرانيا
بالتفجيرات قال ان امريكا لا تستبعد هذا
الامر
هكذا مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بوري الاستمراريه تحقيق في
تفجير خط نوع وذلك بعد نقلت وسائل اعلام
عن مسؤولين امريكيين مجهولين ترجيحهم
مسؤوليه جماعه المواليه لاوكرانيا عن
الهجوم
لست خائفا من الحقيقه نحن نتحدث عن تكهنات
اما التحقيقات فما زالت جاريه في السويد
والدنمارك والمانيا طالما التحقيقات
مستمره فلا نستطيع استخلاص نتائج نهائيه
يجب الانتظار لفهم ما يحدث
عودوا قضيه خط انابيب الى الواجهه مجددا
بعدما كشفت وسائل اعلام المانيه عن تفاصيل
جديده اظهرت في تحقيق خاص تورط اشخاص
اوكرانيين في احدى اكبر عمليات تخريب
والتي تم تنفيذها في سبتمبر الماضي
تلك كانت اولى الصور التي نشرت لم اعتقد
انه تسريب لاحد انابيب الغاز الروسي في
بحر البلطيق الشمالي في سبتمبر الماضي
سرعان ما تاكد الخبر وسرعان ما تبادل
الدول وعده جهات الاتهامات لاكبر عمليه
تخريب تهدد امن الطاقه في اوروبا مع
اشتعال الميدان في اوكرانيا خفت ضجيج
القصه لكن صوتا اخر كان اكثر حذرا ونشاطا
يبحث في خبايا ما حصل
لاشهر عمل سايمر هيرش الصحفي الاستقصائي
الامريكي الشهير على تقديم ادعاء مفصل
يورط الولايات المتحده والنرويج بانفجار
خط نورد ستريم الغازي تقرير هرش فجر قنبله
مفاجئه بوجه الادعاءات الامريكيه التي
اتهمت روسيا بالوقوف وراء العمليه بعد
استخدامها الخط كاداه للضغط على
الاوروبيين وتقديم تنازلات في الحرب
الاوكرانيه
تحقيق دفع الولايات المتحده لتبديل
روايتها حول المتهم وابراز متهم اخر
للتغطيه على تقرير هرش كما يرى مراقبونه
بالنسبه لي انها قصه غريبه بعض الشيء لان
هذه القصه ليس لها علاقه بنا واعتقد ان
التحقيق مع السلطات الرسميه سيصف كل
التفاصيل وسيكون بمثابه مجامله لقواتنا
الخاصه ولكن هذا ليس نشاطنا
اكتشفت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز عن تقييم
للاستخبارات الامريكيه يشير الى ان مجموعه
اوكرانيه نفذت الهجوم
لتتبعها روايه مطابقه ولكنها اكثر تفصيلا
لصحيفه الالمانيه التي كشفت عن تورط فريق
كوماندوس اوكراني بعمليه التفجير اما
روسيا فاسرت بدورها على فتح تحقيق مستقل
دون المماطله لا تزال اسئله وسيناريوهات
كثيره تدور حول الهجوم على نورد ستريم
وربما هناك من يفضل ابقاء الامر قيد
الكتمان لان الاجوبه قد تكون لها عواقب
تهدد بتجاوز الخطوط الحمر التي وضعتها
روسيا في حرب اوكرانيا
افادت وكاله وسوشي بتنفيذ روسيا هجوما او
هجوما صاروخيا كبير شاملا مختلف المدن
الاوكرانيه في مقاله حاكم منطقه خاركيف
ان القوات الروسيه شنت نحو 5 ضربات على
مدينه خارقييف ومنطقتها واستهدفت بنى
تحتيه حيويه بدوره قال حاكم منطقه اوداسا
ان صواريخ اصابه البنيه التحتيه للطاقه في
المنطقه والحقت اضرارا بمبان سكنيه واصفا
ما تعرضت له منطقته بضربه صاروخيه ضخمه
اصدرت وكاله الاستخبارات الامريكيه
تقريرها سنوي الخاص بتقييم المخاطر في
العالم والذي اشارت فيه الى ما وصفته
بالسنوات القادمه الحرجه بسبب روسيا
والصين موسكو ستواصلني تهديد العالم واقل
تقرير ان روسيا ستظل التهديد الاكبر للدول
الاخرى في العالم وستستمر بمحاولاتها
للتاثير على الانتخابات الامريكيه وفيما
يتعلق بالصين اشاره تقييم الاستخبارات لان
بكين ستطور من قدراتها لمواجهه الولايات
المتحده وبشان ايران وتهديداتها تحدث
التقرير عن مواصله طهران تهديد مصالح
واشنطن مضيفا ان ايران ستكون مصدرا
للاضطرابات من خلال ميليشياتها اشار تقرير
الاستخبارات الامريكيه ايضا الى ان ايرانا
لم تاخذ خطوات واضحه لبناء القنبله
النوويه
اكدت ابريل هاينز مديره المخابرات او
ايبروهاينز المديره المخابرات الوطنيه
الامريكيه ان روسيا بحاجه الى تعبئه
اجباريه والى مصدر يمدها بالذخائر ايضا
لتواصل هجومها على اوكرانيا بنفس القوه
لو لم تبدا روسيا تعبئه اجباريه وان لم
تحصل على امدادات عسكريه من طرف ثالث
سيكون من الصعب عليها الاستمرار في الهجوم
بنفس القوه الحاليه خلال الاشهر المقبله
وقد تحول هدفها الى تعزيز السيطره على
مواقعها الحاليه لا نرى ان الجيش الروسي
سيتعفى هذا العام ليحقق مكاسب كبيره ولكن
بوتين يعتقد ان الوقت في صالحه وان
المواطنه في الحرب بما في ذلك وقف القتال
احيانا افضل طريق لتحقيق اهداف روسيا
الاستراتيجيه في اوكرانيا وان استغرق
الامر سنوات
مديره المخابرات الوطنيه الامريكيه اضافت
ان ايران سرعت من جهودها واصبحت قريبه جدا
من الوصول الى القنبله النوويه
اكثر ما يقلقنا ان ايران سرعت برنامجها
النووي بسبب انها لم تعد مقيده بالاتفاق
النووي ونفذت ابحاثا وانشطه قربتها كثيرا
من انتاج الماده الانشطاريه الضروريه
لانتاج سلاح نووي اذا تم اتخاذ قرار بذلك
قال مسؤولون امريكيون واسرائيليون ان وزير
دفاع الامريكي لويد اوستن اضطر الى تغيير
جدول زياره المقرره اليوم الخميس لاسرائيل
وتغيير مكان انعقاد الاجتماع في مصنع
بالقرب من مطار اسرائيل الدولي بناء على
طلب وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه حيث سيلتقي
اوستن مع رئيس الوزراء بنيام نتانياهو
ونظيره الاسرائيلي
واوضح المسؤولون ان تغيير طرا بسبب
الاحتجاجات المناهضه لحكومه نتنياهو والتي
من المتوقع ان تشل حركه المرور في جميع
انحاء البلاد مع توقع اغلاق الطرق وتحذير
السلطات من اضطرابات محتمله في المطر
النقاشات داخل قاعه مجلس المحافظين هنا
حول ايران طغت عليها المخاوف من اثار
اليورانيوم العاليه التخصيب التي عثر
عليها مفتشون تابعون للوكاله في منشاه
فوردو الايرانيه والتي بلغت تقريبا اربعه
وثمانين بالمئه ولكن الدبلوماسيين
الغربيين هنا يقولون انهم يتمهلون
بالتصعيد لاعطاء ايران فرصه لشرح اسباب
العثور على اثار اليورانيوم العالي
التخصيب هذا الدبلوماسيون او الدول
الاوروبيه حذرت حتى ايران من ان عدم اعطاء
جواب لامين عام الوكاله الدوليه رافاييل
جروستي كما وعدت وبشكل سريع سيعرضها
للمحاسبه وقالت بان الرد الذي اعطته حتى
الان غير مقنعه
اسابيع قليله ستظهر ما اذا كانت ايران
ستفي بتعهداتها التي اطلقتها على رافايا
الجروسسي امين عام الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه هنا ام انها تماطل من جديد وهكذا
مماطله ستدفع بالدول الغربيه للدعوه
الاجتماع طارق لمجلس المحافظين كما اكد
لنا دبلوماسيون حتى قبل اجتماع المجلس
الدوري في يونيو المقبل وطرح مشروع قرار
جديد يدين ايران يكون الثالث خلال عام
واحد راغده برنامج
اصدرت عشرات الناشطات الايرانيات في مجال
حقوق المراه بيانا ادنا فيه التسميم
المتعمد والمتسلسل طالبات في المدارس وضعت
الناشطه في بيانهن الى عزل او اقاله وزيري
التربيه والتعليم والصحه لفشلهما في حمايه
حياه وصحه الالاف من الطالبات وطالبه
الناشطات بتشكيل خليه ازمه عاجله بمشاركه
اطباء ومحامين مستقلين وعدد من اسر
الطالبات اضافه الى متخصصين تابعوا عن كتب
هذه الماساه الانسانيه وشددنا على ضروره
تشكيل هذه اللجنه بدعم كامل من منظمه
الصحه العالميه والصليب الاحمر واطباء بلا
حدود وطالبه الناشطات النظام الايراني
باصدار ترخيص لحضور ممثلي هذه المنظمات
والمؤسسات الدوليه الاخرى ذات الصله حتى
تتمكن من جمع المعلومات اللازمه واتخاذ
الاجراءات الفوريه بحق المتورطين
ارسل مجلس النواب الامريكي تمرير مشروعي
قرار قدمه النائب الجمهوري ماد كيدز
يدعو الرئيس جو بايدن الى سحب القوات
الامريكيه من سوريا
وايضا دعم لهذا القرار صوت 103 مشرعين فقط
لصالحه فيما صوت 321 ضده
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه انها
تعطيل طويل الامد لتدفق المساعده
الانسانيه الى سوريا سيكون مصدر قلق لها
وذلك بعد خروج مطار حلب من الخدمه بسبب
ضربه جويه اتهمت وسائل اعلام سوريا
اسرائيليه بالضلوع فيها وكان المطار
يستخدم يستخدم للمساعده في توصيل
المساعدات للمتضررين جراء الزلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا الشهر الماضي
نشعر بالقلق اذا اثار اي اغلاق مطول على
تدفق المساعدات الانسانيه الى المحتاجين
لقد كان مطار حلب بمثابه نقطه هبوط
للمساعدات الانسانيه لاولئك الذين تضرروا
في سوريا من هذا الزلزال المدمر واي اغلاق
مطول للمطار سيكون ذلك مصدر قلق كبير لنا
قال مبعوث الامم المتحده الخاص لسوريا ان
الم
ناخ قد
يجعله مستحيلا مشيرا الى ان الحرب في
اوكرانيا لها تاثير سلبي يعطل من مهمه
السلام
ان المناخ الدولي اليوم قد يجعل الحل
الشمل مستحيلا لا يزال يتعين علينا السعي
لتحقيق ذلك لنكن صريحين عندما ننظر الى
الحرب في اوكرانيا والتاثير الذي تحدثه
فانه لا يساعدنا في تسهيل ذلك لكن كما قلت
لا يمكن قبول الوضع الراهن نحن بحاجه الى
المضي قدما
قبل شهر لم يكن هناك احتمال لفتح المزيد
من المعابر الحدوديه ولا تحركات لتخفيف
العقوبات بطريقه ملموسه لقد راينا تلك
التحركات الان ما نحتاج الى رؤيته هو ان
يتم تطبيق ذلك عندما يتعلق الامر بالمستوى
السياسي فنحن بحاجه الى نفس المنطق الذي
تم تطبيقه على الجبهه الانسانيه ليتم
تطبيقه الان على المستوى السياسي
نش
رت صحنين شو تايمز البريطانيه تقريرا يسلط
الضوء على علاقه الامم المتحده المتشابكه
مع نظام السوري حيث كشف تاخر المنظمه في
ايصال المساعدات الى الشمال السوري التي
تضررا بسبب الزلزال عن عجز المنظمه في بعض
الاحيان في علاج الازمات الانسانيه في
سوريا خصوصا بعد صمود النظام لاكثر من
اثني عشر عاما من الصراع
كانت الساعات الاثنتين والسبعون الاولى من
حدوث زلزال سوريا وتركيا الاكثر حرجا
بالنسبه للعالقين تحت الانقاض
غير ان المعدات اللازمه للانقاذ
والمساعدات الانسانيه حالت دون وصولها الى
الشمال السوري تحديدا مناطق سيطره
المعارضه الاكثر فقرا وفي هذا الشان رات
صحيفه في تايمز ان بطء وصول المساعدات
الدوليه اكدت تلك الاتهامات التي تطال
نظام الاسد وهي ان دمشق نجحت مره اخرى في
تحويل اهتمام العالم بمعاناه شعبها الى
استثمار مربح يعود بالنفع على النظام
واتباعه
تذكر وثائق تم تسريبها في عام 2016 ان
الامم المتحده اضطرت سابقا لتوظيف اقارب
مسؤولين رفيعي المستوى في النظام
يجب ان تكون هناك عمليه سياسيه حقيقيه
يقودها السوريون وتسهلها الامم المتحده
ويجب ان يكون هناك جهد دوري منسق لدعم ذلك
مع عمل جميع اللاعبين الرئيسيين في جهد
متماسك ابنه حسام لوجا رئيس المديريه
العامه للمخابرات السوريه التي تعاقبه
الولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي
والمملكه المتحده بسبب انتهاكات حقوق
الانسان هي مثال بات معروفا لهذه الضغوط
التي يمارسها النظام على المنظمات
الاغاثيه البنت العشرينيه والعهده على
الصحيفه تعمل في مكتب الصندوق المركزي
لمواجهه الطوارئ التابع للامم المتحده في
دمشق
توظيف اجباري تتبعه اقامه الزاميه لموظفي
الجمعيات الاغاثيه في احد الفنادق
المملوكه من رجال اعمال مقربين من النظام
فمنذ عام 2014 دفعت الامم المتحده 81
مليون و600 الف دولار لاقامه موظفيها في
فندق فور سيزونز في دمشق المملوكي لسامر 4
رجل اعمال فرضت واشنطن عقوبات عليه وعلى
الفندق في عام 2019 بسبب ارتباط علاقاته
الماليه بالاسد
ويشير تقرير فانشال تايمز الى ان النظام
يفرض معضله اخلاقيه مستحيله امام المنظمات
الاغاثيه بين اللعب وفقا لقواعد الحكومه
او وقف المساعده عن سوريين محتاجين
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
مجلس الامن يمدد العقوبات المفروضه على
السودان عاما اضافيا
اهلا بكم من جديد مدد مجلس الامن دوليه
العقوبات الدوليه المفروضه على السودان
عاما واحدا متجاهلا بذلك مناشدات الخرطوم
لرفع الحظر على الاسلحه التي فرض ابانا
الحرب التي اندلعت في اقليم دارفور غرب
السودان عام 2003 قرار المجلس الذي صوت
عليه 13 عضوا مع امتناع روسيا والصين عن
التصويت ومدد التفويض الممنوح للجنه لجنه
الخبراء المكلفه بالاشراف على العقوبات
وتطبيقها وعلى حظر الاسلحه لغايه 12 من
مارس 2024
اقر مجلس شيوخ الفرنسي الذي يهيمن عليه
اليمين ماده رئيسيه في مشروع لتعديل نظام
التقاعدي تنص على رفع سن التقاعد من اثنين
الى 64 عاما وذلك على اثر معركه اجرائيه
حاده مع اليسار وقد صوت 201 من الاعضاء
لصالح رفع سن التقاعد مقابل 115 عضوا
صوتوا ضده وياتي اقرار هذه الماده غدا
تطغرات حاشده جرت في فرنسا وشارك فيها
اكثر من مليون شخص وفقا لوزاره الداخليه
احتجاجا على نظام التقاعد في فرنسا
استخدمت الشرطه الجورجيه خراطيم المياه في
محاوله لتفريق المتظاهرين الذين احتشدوا
بالقرب من مبنى البرلمان في تبليسي
اعتراضا على قانون يهدد عمل وسائل الاعلام
والمنظمات غير الحكوميه ولليوم الثاني على
توالي حاول بعض المتظاهرين اقتحام المبنى
لكن الشرطه منعتهم ووصلت شرطه مكافحه
الشغب الى منطقتي مجلس البرلمان في وسط
العاصمه الجورجيه
[موسيقى]
حصل متحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه حكومه
جورجيا على احترام حريه التجمع
والاحتجاجات السلميه ودعا جميع الاطراف
لممارسه ضبط النفس وتجنب اي اعمال تصعيديه
او عنيفه
يحث حكومه جورجيا على احترام حريه التجمع
السلمي والاحتجاجات السلميه وندعو جميع
الاطراف على ممارسه ضبط النفس وتجنب اي
اعمال تصعيديه او عنيفه مع احترام سياده
القانون والقيم الديمقراطيه في جورجيا
اطلقت شرطه مكافحه الشغابه التركيه مسحوق
الفلفل لتفريق مجموعه من المتظاهرين
تشاجروا مع قوات الشرطه في نهايه مسيره
للاحتفال بيوم المراه العالمي في وسط
اسطنبول
في يوم المراه العالمي مسحوق الفلفل
لتفريق المتظاهرات في تركيا
[موسيقى]
شرطه مكافحه الشغب التركيه اطلقت مسحوق
الفلفل لتفريق نحو 2000 امراه في وسط
اسطنبول
السلطات المحليه كانت قد منع التنظيم اي
مسيره او احتجاجات او بيانات صحفيه في وسط
المدينه
التركيات اثناء محاولاتهن دفع دروع الشرطه
دعينا الى استقاله الحكومه
المتظاهرات هتفنا لن نسكت ولسنا خائفات
ولا ننحني
الاشتباكات مع الشرطه تاتي قبل اكثر من
شهرين من الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه التركيه
نشره الى العناوين
الخارجيه الامريكيه لا تستبعد طورت
اوكرانيا
التي تتحدث عن تورط واشنطن بالسخيفه
[تصفيق]
في تحدي الاحتجاجات شارع الفرنسي مجلس
الشيوخ يقر رفع سن التقاعد من 62 الى 64
عاما
ولليوم الثاني على التوالي اشتباكات عنفه
دائما العربيه تعطيك مشاهدينا نعود
والقاكم بعد دقائق الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]